[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
talking about footwork in Aikido as part
of our week-long series here on footwork
and what footwork is in height up there
are just a few basic steps we use in
Aikido and if you memorize those basic
steps and get really good at them all of
your Aikido footwork will benefit so
meaning there's only really a few simple
ways we move in Aikido we either going
to be standing still so in our rope no
kamae or on me stance we're either going
to be or Tsuyoshi so that's a sliding
step forward a you meenakshi a regular
walking step forward or tin con and
that's turning around there's also a chi
co shoe which is kind of an about-face
and we're gonna talk about Chi she a
little bit too but other than that
everything is just a combination of
those footwork steps so I can't really
has a small set of footwork and once you
master that small set of footwork you
can apply it to absolutely anything you
can do so we're gonna cover those right
now in this video I'm gonna get Josh to
come on in we're gonna talk about
footwork okay so we're gonna talk about
the basic footwork positions in Aikido
so we have our basic rope whoo no kamae
or a hundy stance so that's how we stand
19 oh it's a little T stance with all
kinds of little nicknames for it but
that's how job should be organized he's
got a basic set of steps that he's going
to do he's either going to do a Tsuyoshi
or he's going to do an IU Miyaichi or
he's going to do a tin con a basic term
or a chi shashi and about-face
if those the basic thought patterns he's
going to use all the time pretty much no
matter what he does so yeah she's as
simple as sliding forward on the front
foot now when I first learned Aikido the
style we used we didn't have a word for
Tsuyoshi so when I first came across
like Peter Sal's using the word tsuki ah
she was like that's a godsend because I
always had a hard time telling my
students to go like this instead of like
this so we'd be doing some technique and
I would say step forward and they'd go
like this oh not that one do it
sliding step portals so if you have
terminology for most sukiyaki and they
you mean Oishi it makes like a lot
easier when you're explain to your
students or as a student when you're
conveying to your since a what it is you
want to talk about so sudhi ash's
sliding step a you me ah she is walking
step 10 Kahn is a turn so Josh turns
around perfect and of course he could do
those from either side and Acacia she is
an about-face just like that right so
he's just flipping his feet over now we
can put these in any series of
combination we want so for example josh
can do a city ahi followed by a ten Khan
so his front foot slides in and they
just attend Khan he can also do an A you
mean ah she followed by ten Khan and
that's really common for IQ to work
we'll talk about that one later that's a
very special step it's called the
two-step in a lot of schools or the
eating meat in Khan it's a very very
important step to do but that's just my
you mija she followed by a ten conscious
that's he gave me ah she didn't Khan he
could also do a cry she I she he could
do a ciggy ah she cries she or Akai she
ought she said yah G right so he can put
into any kind of combination of these
together right so you get the idea we
don't need to have to show you all that
but the idea is that these fundamental
steps which is your sukiyaki a you me a
sheet in Connick I she can be combined
into any combination of things now we
have a special one which is eating meat
in Cana or the two-step and there's a
ton of reasons it'll it'll start showing
up but we're not gonna talk about that
until we start getting into how you
interplay with someone else and why that
step is so important these are the basic
footwork patterns that we use in Aikido
I'm Christopher hi and thanks for
watching